a gilded helicopters adorning trees all
over the country as the 2019 White House
Historical Association x' christmas
ornament correspondent David spud has
the story of the decoration from concept
to hang it on your tree inside this
building the production line is humming
as dozens of employees work long hours
to make this year's White House
Christmas ornament it's really exciting
to see what we can accomplish
Dave Markie is the president of Khem art
a second-generation veteran owned family
business in lincoln rhode island tim
arts began producing fifteen hundred
white house themed ornaments in 1981 at
the request of First Lady Nancy Reagan
this year they're approaching 1 million
all put together by hand
they're people putting this thing
together using a tab and slot system
that we've developed with a pair of
pliers they release a new design every
year paying tribute to the presidents in
sequential order the first ornament
honored George Washington the 1999
ornament features the portrait of
Abraham Lincoln hanging in the state
dining room the 2008 Benjamin Harrison
ornament marks the first traditional
Christmas tree in the White House the
2019 ornament is unlike the rest a
3-dimensional helicopter on the White
House South Lawn every year is exciting
with the White House but I think this
one's one of the most exciting is
because it really pushed that technology
to limit it's a tribute to president
number 34 Dwight D Eisenhower he was the
first American president to use a
helicopter for presidential travel and
the president of the White House
Historical Association believes this
year's ornament honors some of the most
iconic images that come from the White
House so when you see that majestic
helicopter fly in land on the South Lawn
of the White House and the president of
the first family disembark it reminds
you that that this is represents the
United States of America in Washington
David's punt Fox News